the war in ukraine thousands of miles
away but it has impacted and affected so
many here at home one las vegas woman
says these last few weeks have been
excruciating as her daughter escaped
from kiev now she just wants to bring
her here to the united states sasha
loftis live in studio joining us with
her story
brian it's every mother's worst
nightmare knowing your child is in
danger and not being able to help them
this woman's daughter fled from a war
zone and she had no choice but to wait
helplessly here in las vegas
question is why why it's happening days
go by as the destruction of war
continues in ukraine
and tatiana clee's pain is all-consuming
i cannot keep silence and silently wait
the ukrainian native is now an american
citizen and moved here to las vegas in
2014 but both her daughters still live
overseas her oldest lalia was living in
kiev when russia first invaded a few
weeks ago she said mom what happened i
said you know it's a voice start now the
27 year old had to leave everything
behind and escape to poland with her mom
waiting helplessly a world away i was
waiting
in the morning at
her evening
to understand she alive or not tatiana's
goal is to bring her child safely to
southern nevada
in 2018 she filed an i-130 petition
which allows family of united states
citizen to live here permanently why she
have to be a refugee in different
country
if i can help you here she planned for a
long wait but the state of the world has
changed her circumstances and she hopes
by sharing lilia's story she can help
others understand exactly what's at
stake i'm your mother
i can give you
a home
tatiana says lilia house found temporary
housing just outside of warsaw poland
her other daughter is also safe living
in crimea she says due to kovid she
hasn't seen either of her children in
close to three years brian